hey bud happy graduation
you just received a full ride
scholarship to Berkeley and that
intimidates you after your California
high school all-star game against
Florida you realize that you don't know
nearly as much about football as you
could and now it seems that life is
pointing you in that direction and yet
you're questioning the point of pursuing
football and beyond that you are
questioning your reasons for living you
felt discouraged and even shunned by
friends and family your whole life
hearing the word [ __ ] out of the mouths
of your loved ones and knowing that
they're talking about you you a gay
football player I know you think that's
an oxymoron and that's why your first
goal is to make sure no one finds out I
know you are in pain I know you are
confused I know you are battling an
inner turmoil that will last another
decade breathe you're about to enter the
toughest years of your life you're gonna
succeed at a sport that serves as your
cover
[Music]
while your house you're even going to be
voted the best offensive lineman by your
opposing peers they all think you're a
force to be reckoned with they see this
potential in you that you have trouble
seeing in yourself you will make it all
the way to the NFL playing first for the
New England Patriots and then for the
Kansas City Chiefs
[Applause]
you're going to invest all of your
energy and time into football
so people refrain from asking your least
favorite question where's your
girlfriend you're going to start chewing
tobacco in order to look more straight
don't do it you're going to gain as much
weight as possible so that people see
you is unattractive you're gonna do
everything in your power to make sure no
one finds out that you're gay you know
that if your cover is blown you'll lose
everything if you're gay you're as good
as dead
you will live 29 years of your life in
fear you'll keep up this facade because
you think there is no alternative you
will want to escape the anxiety to feel
something other than trapped
[Music]
this is why you will abuse drugs
especially painkillers you will even
spend and donate hundreds of thousands
of dollars because you have no intention
of needing it because after your NFL
career you plan to take your own life
but you won't your athletic trainer will
notice your downward spiral and
convinced you to talk to a counselor
this will be the turning point for your
whole life and give you the strength
necessary to find out that people love
you your family your friends and your
dogs
you will realize Ryan that you have been
scared of nothing
this is not the end no this is just the
beginning you will soon feel free for
the first time in your life heck you
might even find love with someone who
understands you and your struggle so
again breathe really breathe believe it
or not it gets better for you and soon
you will want to share this newfound
happiness in love with the world just
hang in there a little longer buddy one
day people will look up to you for your
strength
[Music]